اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بابرز العناوين
حرب البنيه التحتيه تستعر تفجير خطرسي
لتصدير الامونيا موسكو تتهموكيا وتحذر من
تجميع العالم
اتفاق سعودي امريكي على العمل لتحقيق
السلام بالسودان واليمن وبلينكن يؤكد ان
امريكا باقيه في المنطقه
واشنطن تطالب وكاله الطاقه بمحاسبه ايران
وتشدد على ان وصولها لنسب التخصيب الحاليه
خطا لا يجب تكراره
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
تختنق بدخان حرائق كندا وتصبح اكثر مدن
العالم تلوثا والسلطات توقف رحلات جويه
لضعف الرؤيه
اهلا بكم لم تكت تمر 24 ساعه على التفجير
الذي دمر جسر نوفا كخوفكا الا ووقع تفجير
جديد لكنه هذه المره طال خط تصدير
الامونيا بين مدينتي تولياتي واوديسا
بمقاطعه خرك وانتشرت صور تظهر حجم الضرر
والتسرب الناتج عن التفجير الذي وصفته
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بالعمل التخربيبي
في حوالي الساعه التاسعه مساء بتوقيت
موسكو فجرت مجموعه استطلاع الاوكرانيه خط
انابيب بتولياتي للامونيا بالقرب من منطقه
خاركيف ونتيجه لهذا العمل الارهابي وقعت
اصابات في صفوف السكان المدنيين وقد تم
تزويدهم بالمساعده الطبيه اللازمه وفي
الوقت الحالي يتم تصريف بقايا الامونيا من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عبر الاجزاء المتضرره
من خط الانابيب
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
زخرفه قالت ان اصلاحها خط انابيب الامونيا
سيستغرق بين شهر وثلاثه وحذرت من ان ذلك
قد يزيد نسبه الجوعه في العالم
وفقا للمعلومات المتاحه في الخامس من
يونيو تم تفجير خط انابيب الامونيا
في منطقه خاضعه لسيطره اوكرانيا نعم انها
نفس منشاه البنيه التحتيه المدنيه التي تم
ذكرها مرارا وتكرارا كجزء من اتفاق حبوب
البحر الاسود وبسبب استهدافها تم اخراج
احدى محطات الضخ من الخدمه وتشغيل صمامات
الاغلاق ومع ذلك تسربت المواد الخام وفقا
للتقييم الاولي ستستغرق اعمال السياره
والاصلاح لا يقرب من شهر الى ثلاثه اشهر
وينضم الينا من كاف السفير فولوديمير
شوماكوف الدبلوماسي السابق اهلا بك سيد
يعني اذا كان تفجير سد كخوفكا امس قد يضر
بالجانبين الروسي وايضا الاوكراني كيف تصف
اليوم التفجير خط الامونيا خاصه وبان هذا
الخط يضر
بالمصالح الروسيه الاحاديه وقد يؤدي الى
جوع بالعالم كيف يمكن لاوكرانيا ان تبرر
ان ليس لها يد في ما حصل اليوم
[موسيقى]
ولكن بالمنطق كيف يمكن
لروسيا ان تضرب نفسها بنفسها يعني ان تضر
باستهداف سد كخوفكا وهو الذي يزود مناطق
القرن بالمياه العذبه والان خط الامونيا
يعني لم تضر بنفسها اين المنطق بذلك
اولا حول المونيوم هذا الخطوط كان من
الممكن اولا استفزازات ولكن احاول الصاد
في نواكحو كي ينبغي ادراك بان هذا الضرر
الضخم ليست لروسيا ولكن لاوكرانيا ودولنا
نتذكر
عندما القوات مصالحه كانت التراجع وفي من
جيش اوكرانيا لم يدمر هذا الصوت لم يدمر
اي جسور لان كانت بصراحه بصفه عامه في
صالح اوكرانيا تضمير كلها
تعرق الهجوم جيش روسيا ولكن في شهر نوفمبر
عند مرور صح هربوا من خرسون ومن ضيفه
غربيه وهم تامروا كل بنيه تحقيق اساسيه
وكل البنيه تحتيه للطاقه والان في محافظه
خرسون نحن نشاهد الكارثه كارثه الضخمه
لسكان هذا المنطقه للاسف الشديد المايا هي
مصممه كمان التربه هي مصممه هذه
هو كمان ضمره مقابر وكمان مقابر مع جنود
تروس مع الجثه في منطقه
الجنوط روسيا
في منطقه
تسريب العيش من محطه نوويه وفي هذا الحاله
سوف تكون مصممه اغلبيه من الاراضي
الزراعيه في اوكرانيا وخاصه في مدينه
محافظه يعني في جنوب اوكرانيا في منطقه
الباص وجزئيا في شمال اوكرانيا واكيد
تفجير هذا الساق وليس في الصالح اوكرانيا
سيد ابقى معي لنعرف وضع الجنود الروس في
هذا السد حيث نقلت شبكه سي ان ان
الامريكيه عن القوات الاوكرانيه في خرسون
ان العديد من الجنود الروس قتلوا او
اصيبوا جراء تفجير سد كخاف كافيه خرسون
جنوب اوكرانيا واوضح الجيش الاوكراني ان
الجيش الروسي رغم انه عمد الى تفجير السد
الا انه لم يبلغ جنوده للحفاظ على عنصر
المفاجاه ما ادى الى غمر المناطق التي
كانوا يسيطرون عليها بالمياه وغرق بعضهم
وخلال اتصال مع نظيره التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وصف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
تفجيرا سد نوفا كخوفكا بالعمل البربري من
قبل اوكرانيا وبتحريض من الغرب بينما دعا
اردوغان الى اجراء تحقيق دوليا حول تدمير
السد
انفجار سد كخوفكا في اوكرانيا ستصل
تاثيراته الى ابعد من المحيط القريب فقط
وتقاذف الاتهامات طبعا بين الجانبين مستمر
السد تم بنائه باستخدام التربه المضغوطه
التي تعتبر طريقه لامتصاص
الانفجارات الشديده من هنا ظهرت فكره ان
التفجير تم من الداخل في الجانب الميداني
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق اندريه
زاكورود نيوك لمجله نيوزويك ان اي هجوم
اوكراني محتمل عبر دهرنابر اصبح الان
مستحيلا فعليا لماذا لانه على احد جانبي
النهر مشاهدينا يوجد خطر على محطه
زابوريجيا للطاقه النوويه التي يعتمد نظام
التبريد فيها على المياه المخزنه بسد
كخفقه والان ومع انخفاض مستوى المياه فيه
قد يؤدي ذلك الى انهيار وحدوث كارثه نوويه
لن تقتصر فقط على اوروبا اذا انفجر السد
ومهما كان المتسبب بالتفجير فمن المرجح ان
تتضرر روسيا وتحديدا في شبه جزيره القرم
التي اقتطعتها موسكو من اوكرانيا قبل تسعه
اعوام تدمير السد يمكن ان يعرض للخطر
امدادات المياه العذبه لشبه جزيره القرم
والحديث هنا عن قناه شمال القرن تحديدا
التي تزود
عبرها روسيا شبه الجزيره بالمياه العذبه
طبعا هذه القناه كانت توفر حوالي
85% من مياه شبه جزيره القرم ومعظمها كان
يستخدم للزراعه ثم ايضا بمجالات الصناعه
والاستهلاك العام وسيطره القوات الروسيه
على القناه في اليوم الاول من الحرب التي
انطلقت في فبراير من العام الماضي عندما
تقدمت مجموعات روسيه شمالا من شبه جزيره
القرم للسيطره على القناه
[موسيقى]
من جديد ينضم الينا من كاف السفير فولدي
ميرجونا الدبلوماسي السابق اهلا بك من
جديد سيد يعني الاوكراني ينفون بدء الهجوم
المضاد بالمقابل هناك تقارير غربيه تتحدث
بانه الرئيس الروسي
بوتين قد علم بانه سيخسر القرم وبالتالي
عمد الى تفجير السد بمعنى اخر يريد تفجير
الارض ومن عليها
كيف تفسر هذا التضارب في التصريحات
والتنسيق بين اوكرانيا والغرب
اولا بالنسبه لاكيد صعب تعليق اي تعليقات
السيد بوتين عموما هذا
المعلومات عاريه من الصحه بالمناسبه
التعليقه حول السد ان هذا
السطرمه
تاثير صواريخ وكنابل ان كان انفجار من
الداخل من المستحيل تدمير كل هذه البنيه
تحتيه الاساسيه الضخمه بصاروخ او صاروخين
يعني اكيد كان انفجار من داخل بالمناسبه
بهذا التدمير هذا الصوت نحن نشاهد تلميح
من بانه هو مستعد اتخاذ ارشاد التدابير ضد
اوكرانيا يدور حديث حتى تدمير محطه نوويه
زباديجه او حتى استخدام اسلحه نوويه بيت
اوكرانيا كمان نحن نعطيك بان روسيا
مثل عمل انتقامي قبل
من محافظه خرصون من ضيفه الشرقيه كما
روسيا عملت في ضيفه غربيه في شهر نوفمبر
يعني على كل حال نحن نشاهد
التفاقم الصراع بين طرفين بان نحن نشاهد
وهي مستعده لاتخاذ اي تدبير لواقف هجوم
قوات مصالحه اوكرانيه وهذا لا يصعد لروسيا
بالمناسبه كمان تعليق حول هذا الكنائيه
بصراحه تقريبا
في 2016 اوكرانيا
يعني
بدون مياه خالد نيبرو من الخونه لمده سته
او حتى سابع سنوات يعني بدون اي مشاكل
يعني معروف بان داخل الان الخزانات مع
المياه وحوضات مع مياه مليانه يعني كمان
داخل الشبه الجزيره
الانهار محليه يعني بصفه عامه في اقرب وقت
لم تكون المشاكل كبيره مع مياه داخل شبه
جزيره يعني اكيد في صالح روسيا تدمير هذا
لتعرق الهجوم مضادات المتوقعه قوه مصالحه
واضرار لاكتساط اوكراني بصراحه هو هايله
جدا على وطننا لهذا للاسف الشديد روسيا
ترتكب اباده جمعيه على ضيفه شرقيه الان هي
لا تنظم عمليه الاجلاء في هذا المنطقه
للاسف الشديد وهناك للضحايا موجود بين
الفكره شكرا جزيلا لك من كاف السفير
فولوديمير
الدبلوماسيه السابق شكرا جزيلا لك
تفجير سد نوفا كخوفكا جنوبي اوكرانيا فتح
نيران الاتهامات المتبادله بين الروس
والاوكران السد يقع في خرسون التي تعد
الجغرافيا مدينه اوكرانيه لكنها تخضع
لسيطره روسيه الطرفان يتبادلان الاتهامات
حول من فجر السد اما الصحف الغربيه فتحدثت
عن الفرضيات الاكثر ترجيحا صحيفه
الفرضيه الروسيه التي تقول انه عمل تخريبي
متعمد من قبل الاوكران عن طريق قصف جوي
بهدف حرمان شبه جزيره القرم من المياه لكن
الاوكران يتحدثون عن انفجار داخل غرفه
المحرك الرئيسيه لسد نوفا كخوفكا عن طريق
الغام وضعها الروس في البنيه الداخليه
للسد ما ولد انفجارا داخليا ضخما الاوكران
يدفعون بنظريه ان قصف سد نوفاك خوفك من
الخارج لن يؤثر على هيكله الخارجي
بالطريقه التي حدثت خاصه وان السده ترابي
تم بناؤه من خلال ضغط طبقات متتاليه من
التربه باستخدام موا د مقاومه للاختراق
محاطا بحجاره صلبه وخرسان مسلحه امر يقول
خبراء لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز انه لو تم
داخليا فسيتطلب مئات الارطال من المتفجرات
لاحداث خرق في هيكل السد لكن في المقابل
فان احداث نفس الاثر عبر القصف الخارجي
يتطلب كميات مضاعفه من المتفجرات
تدمير سد نوفا خوفكا ليس تفجير الاول الذي
تشهده اوكرانيا صحيفه تيليجرافي
البريطانيه قالت ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يسير على خطى سلفه
جوزيفستالين يزود اعتقاد بان السالين امر
بتفجير سد زابوريا في عام 1941 ما تسبب
حينها بمقتل ما يتراوح بين 20 ومائه الف
شخص
الهدم المتعمد للسدود امر مالوف خلال
الحروب وتكرر في عده دول حول العالم
والهدف دائما واحد احداث فيضانات لاعاقه
القوات المقابله من التقدم واجبارها على
التراجع
[موسيقى]
قررت اداره الطيران الفيدرالي الامريكي
وفرح رحلات جويه الى مدينه نيويورك بسبب
ضعف الرؤيه الناتجه عن حرائق الغابات اقلت
اداره الطيران ان الرحلات الجويه المتجهه
الى مطار نيويورك اما توقفت مؤقتا او
تاخرت عن موعد وصولها في مغطى دخان
الحرائق سماء نيويورك ومبنى الامم المتحده
وينضم الينا من نيويورك الصحفي طارق
الدمشقي اهلا بك السيد طارق يعني الى جانب
توقيف حركه الطيران بشكل جزئي في مدينه
نيويورك هل من اجراءات خاصه تم اتخاذها من
قبل السلطات
تحيه لك راويه نعم هناك يعني عمده مدينه
نيويورك ادم صرح اليوم ان هذه الكثافه من
الدخان الذي تتعرض لها المنطقه عموما بسبب
حرائق الغابات في كندا لم تشهد مثلها
البلاد منذ عام 1960 يعني منذ 60 عاما هذا
التلوث دفع
العمده الى اتخاذ قرارات بمنع الانشطه
الخارجيه بشكل عام الى على كافه المارس
الموجوده في المنطقه كذلك ولايه نيوجيردي
القريبه جدا من مدينه نيويورك المحاذيه
لها اتخذت اجراءات مماثله هناك دعوه كبيره
تحث الناس على البقاء في اماكن المغلقه في
منازلهم او في اماكن عملهم عدم الخروج عند
الا عند الضروره القصوى
التلوث وصل الى درجه جدا عاليه ولكن
يعني المرشد للنظر ان حكومه مدينه نيويورك
ابدت استعدادات ورفعت الجاهزيه في
المستشفيات لاستقبال حالات الربو الازمات
الربو وايضا
الازمات القلبيه لانهم هناك توقعات
يتوقعون ان هذه
هذا الجو المتلوث سوف يؤدي الى حالات
كبيره جدا من ازمات قلبيه وازمات ربو فهم
على اعلى استعداد الان لذلك انا الان في
الخارج جالس في سيارتي واستطيع ان انقل
لكم الصوره ان ما يحدث الان في يعني في
هذه المناطق ناطحات السحاب العاليه جدا
المعروفه في مدينه نيويورك يعني لا استطيع
ان ارى القريبه مني نتيجه هذا التلوث بسبب
الدخان الحاله تشبه نوعا ما العواصف
الرمليه التي تصيب الدول العربيه في
الخليج خصوصا مثل العجاج ولكن لا يوجد
غبار ولكنه دخان تستطيعين ان تشعري بحرقه
في العين
الجفاف في الحلق ضيق في التنفس هناك بعض
الاطباء ينصحون الناس ان ياخذوا موسع
للقصبات للتعامل مع هذه الازمه حتى وان
كانوا في الداخل
يعني حيث تتواجد انت بما انك
على الطريق يعني هل هناك شلل بحركه السير
بما انه هناك نصائح من السلطات بعدم
الخروج الا في الحالات القصوى وهل تم
تسجيل اي حالات اختناق حتى الان الى جانب
رفع جهوزيات المستشفيات
لا توجد يعني تصريحات رسميه عن التسبب هذا
الامر حتى الان بحالات وفاه او اختناق
ولكن هناك الجميع يعني الجميع الاجهزه
الحكوميه الصحيه جاهزه بسبب توقعات
الخبراء ان نسبه ازمات الربو والازمات
القلبيه سوف تزداد بشكل كبير اما على
الحركه المروريه فهي نوعا ما عاديه لا
استطيع ان اقول انها غير اعتياديه الامر
الامر يعني بالنسبه لسكان نيويورك
والمناطق المحيطه بها حتى الان يعتبر يعني
مفاجاه لهم لم احد يتوقع ان تكون هذه
الغيمه الدخانيه سيئه لهذه الى هذه الدرجه
والان التصريحات الحكوميه تقول لهم ان هذا
الامر سوف يزداد قليلا او سوف يبقى على
حاله الى يوم الجمعه لذلك
يحثونهم بشده على البقاء في الاماكن
المغلقه واستخدام الجسم التكييف وايضا وضع
الكمامات
كما كان في حال ايام ازمه كورونا
وحثوهم على نوع الكمامه
الخامسه والتسعين هذا الرقم
i95 انها هي افضل كمامه ممكن ان تكون
للحمايه من هذا الدخان اذا اضطررت الى
الخروج الى الخارج ولكن الدعوه العامه
البقاء داخل المنازل في التكييف وعدم فتح
الموافذ ويعني الكل ياخذ اعلى درجات
الحيطه كما تفعل الان الحكومه على عالم
مستويات انشطه المدارس تقريبا يعني
الخارجيه التغت بشكل كامل بكل المنطقه
ليست فقط في منطقه نيويورك كما ذكرت لك في
منطقه
القريبه جدا من نيويورك هذا يعني ما
استطيع ان انقله حتى الان
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد طارق الدمشقي الصحافي
من نيويورك شكرا جزيلا
عبر الهاتف ايضا ينضم الينا من عمان كابتن
طيار مدني السيد يوسف الدعجه اهلا بك سيد
يوسف يعني موقع اي كيو ار
قال بانه مؤشر جوده الهواء في نيويورك
اليوم وصل الى 167 درجه لتحتل بذلك
المرتبه الثانيه عالميا من حيث رداءت
الهواء بعد العاصمه الهنديه نيودلهي كيف
يمكن وصف الصوره التي نشاهدها مباشره من
مدينه نيويورك
مساء الخير
صحيح الوضع سيء جدا في مدينه نيويورك او
في ولايه نيويورك من الحرائق التي
ذكرتموها وهي لم تحدث منذ 1960 الجو
وصل لدرجه من درجه انعدام الرؤيه خصوصا من
الحالات الطائرات الى درجه لربما يصعب ان
يكون هنالك هبوط واقلاع في المطارات
المتواجد في هذه الحرائق لان هذه الحرائق
وهذا الاشيز اللي هو الرماد من الحرائق لا
يرتفع الى طبقات الجو العليا ولا تؤثر على
الطائرات من الناحيه التقنيه ولكن سوف
تؤثر على الطائرات في حاله الاقلاع
والهبوط ولكن الطائرات الحديثه مجهزه
باجهزه بحيث تستطيع ان تهبط في حاله اذا
كانت حتى مدى الرؤيه صفر يعني لا يكون
هناك رؤيه وهذه بحاجه الى طيارين مهره
ومتدربين والطائره يجب ان تكون مجهزه لهذا
الامريكي اعلن عن توقف جزئي لحركه الطيران
بالنيويورك هل يمكن بما انه تتحدث عن
هل يمكن ان يستمر اكثر اما من
ناحيه الطائره خصوصا تبع الطائره سوف يقوم
بشفط هذه الغبار وادخالها الى المكيفات
الداخليه والى اجهزه الطائره الداخليه
وهذا يتطلب نوع من الصيانه والتنظيف
والقوست العالي على شركات الطائرات ولربما
يعرض الحاله
الجسديه والحاله النفسيه داخل الطائر
عندما يستنشقون ثاني اكسيد الكربون من من
هذه الغبار والاشز المتناثره في الجو يؤثر
عليهم صحيا ولربما قاموا بدعوات قضائيه
الى هذه
على الشركات ولكن يفضل في هذه الحالات في
الذات اللا يقترب التيار من المنطقه التي
يوجد فيها هذه الغبار لانها تؤثر على
اجهزه الطائره تؤثر على الطائره تؤثر على
صحه الطيارين
والمسافرين لانهم سوف يقومون باستنشاق
ثاني اكسيد الكربون ولربما دخل بعضهم في
حاله غيبوبه وهذا امر صعب جدا وبراي انه
سوف يقوموا باغلاق المجال الجوي تحت عشره
الاف قدم في مدينه نيويورك او المدينه او
المناطق المحيطه في هذه الحرائق ونرجو
السلام للجميع باذن الله سيد يوسف يعني
درجه يعني فرض هذا القرار تتحدث عن
كيلومترات معينه يعني كيف تختلف
الطبقات الجو كما
هي مكيفه او موجوده
ثقيل جدا لا يرتفع الى اكثر من عشره الاف
قدم لربما بالكثير فطبقات الجو العليا او
اللي هي المجال الجوي لن يغلق ولكن الهبوط
والاقلاع هو من سوف يتاثر لان الانشز وهي
من الحرائق وهي الرماد خلينا نحكي من
الحراك والاشجار تكون ثقيله وهذه تهبط الى
مستويات المستويات
الواطيه في في الجوي الدنيا نعم خلال
الهبوط والاقناع هنا تكمن الخطوره ويجب
على شركات الطيران او الطيار بالذات هو
صاحب المسؤوليه ان يقوم باختيار مطار بديل
غير مطارات التي تكون في محيط
السيد يوسف تنصح في هكذا حالات الطيارين
باختيار مدينه اخرى ربما او مطار اخر
لضمان الهبوط الامن نصائح دعنا نذكر
بنصائح سيد يوسف من جديد يعني في حال
امتدت هذه او حصلت باماكن اخرى
طبعا يا سيدتي ويوجد بروسيس وتعليمات في
الطيار يعلمها في حاله وجود اللي هو
الحرائق من الاشجار او الحرائق الارضيه او
لربما البراكين هنالك تعليمات وواضحه عدم
الدخول الى هذه المناطق ويجب الابتعاد
عنها حتى لا تؤثر على اجهزه الطائره لان
في اجهزه الطائره هي دقيقه وحساسه وغاليه
جدا يعني بعض الكمبيوتر يكلف 3 مليون 4
مليون واذا دخلت علي هذه الغبار تعطله
وتعطل الطائره وربما عطلت اجهزه الطائره
وتوجيه الطائره
فلربما انها عرضت السلام الجويه للطائره
وعرضت الركاب للخطوره فانا انصح وربما هذه
التعليمات
سوف يقومون باصدار بوليتن للطيارين
والمطارات باغلاقها او الاتجاه الى مطار
بديل بعيد
عن هذه الحاله الجويه او الحاله الحرائق
الحاصله ليان الان في الشرقيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ولربما لا ننسب لن تكون
فقط نيويورك سوف تكون نيويورك
عنه يعني قد تتاثر مدن اخرى كمدينه
نيويورك نعم
هذه الولايات اللي هي على السواحل الشرقيه
الامريكيه الممتده الى الشمال الشرقي من
كندا شرقي مونتريال
سوف تتاثر هذه المنطقه كلها من لانه
الرياح غربيه وسوف تقوم بدفع هذه الغبار
الى الجنوب الشرقي ناحيه السواحل الشرقيه
الامريكيه وخصوصا مدينه نيويورك
سوف تتاثر سوف تتاثر تاثرا كاملا ولربما
سوف تتعطل السياحه لا ننسى على شلالات
نياجرا في بافلو في الشمال لنيويورك وهي
على الحدود الكنديه وهي مشتركه سوف تتعطل
السياحه 100% وسوف يكون بحاجه الى ايام
كثيره حتى يقوموا باصلاح او تنظيف ما خلفت
هذه الحرائق بعد انتهاء هذه الحرائق بكم
يوم او اسبوع يمكن ان تعود الرؤيه واضحه
ويمكن للطياره ان تطير بامان دون الاضرار
بالمحركات او حتى بالركاب من خلال الهواء
الذي يتنشقونه
كما ذكرت سابقا الحرائق
والاشز والمتناثر من هذه الحرائق يهبط الى
طبقات الجو
السفلى ثم يهبط الى الارض
خلال سويعات ربما او ايام ولكن لنتذكر
شيئا ان بعد كل حرائق سوف تكون هنالك
امطار رعديه سبحان الله
وتنظف المجال الجوي المجال الجوي لن يكون
عليه اي خطوره بعد انتهاء الحرائق لربما ب
24 ساعه على 48 ساعه المجال الجوي في في
طبقات الجو
السفلى اللي تحت 10,000 قدم لن سوف تتاثر
اما طبقات الجو العليا لن تصل هذه
العاجز او الى هذه الطبقات ربما تحتاج الى
ايام وفي بعض المناطق المطارات يقوم
بتنظيفها يعني بجوز خلال ساعات لانها لن
تكون بهذاك التاثير التي تتراكم كما هي
الفلكانيك اللي هي البراكين البراكين
بحاجه الى ايام وربما اسابيع حتى تنظيف
المناطق حول المطار لانها مواد من
البتروليه التي تلتصق وتلصق في اجهزه
الطائره وهي اقل الحراقه اقل اقل خطوره من
الفلكانيك حياك الله
اذا الكابتن الطيار المدني يوسف الدعجه
لو سالتك لعجزتي عن الرد وزير خارجيه
اسرائيل يوبخ كما لهاريس تابعونا بعض
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه الى الوزير فيصل بن فرحانه بحث
في الرياض مع نظيره الامريكي
العلاقات الاستراتيجيه بين المملكه واشنطن
وسبل تعزيز التعاون الثنائي الخارجيه
الامريكيه اوضحت بدورها ان بلينكن والامير
فيصل بن فرحانه تعهد بمواصله العمل
لمكافحه الارهاب وتعزيز الاستقرار والامن
وخفض التصعيد في المنطقه كما تعهد بمواصله
التعاون لانهاء القتال في السودان ودعم
الجهود لتحقيق السلام دائم في اليمن
قالت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان ان
اجتماع وزراء خارجيه مجلس التعاون الخليجي
وامريكا الذي عقد في الرياضه بحث تكثيف
العمل الخليجي الامريكي والتنسيق المشتركي
في العديد من القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه
واضافت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان ان
الاجتماع تطرق الى العديد من القضايا
السياسيه والامنيه كما تناول الاجتماع
وجهات النظر حيال الجهود المبذوله للوصول
الى حلول عادله للعديد من الازمات التي
تمر بها منطقه الشرق الاوسط والعالم بما
يسهم في تعزيز الامن والسلم الدوليين
وخلال اجتماعه مع وزراء خارجيه مجلس
التعاون الخليجي في الرياضه اكد بلينكن ان
منطقه الخليج العربي هي في قلبي رؤيه
الولايات المتحده لشرق اوسط اكثر استقراره
كما اكد الرئيس بايدن خلال زيارته لجده في
العام الماضي فالولايات المتحده باقيه في
المنطقه وسنبقى مستثمرين في شراكاتنا معكم
جميعا من اجل بناء مستقبل مشرق في الشرق
الاوسط وبلا شك فان منطقه الخليج العربي
هي قلب رؤيتنا لشرق اوسط اكثر استقرارا
وامانا وازدهارا واندماجا نحن نعمل معا من
اجل التوصل الى حل للنزاع في اليمن
اذا الكريم لان الان يتحدث عن اتصال هاتفي
جامعه بوتين ووليد عهد السعودي تم خلاله
بحث
وتثمين التعاون في اطار ابيك بلس
ومناقشه اسعار الطاقه العالميه اذا بنكن
شدد كذلك على اهميه وحده الاراضي السوريه
وسيادتها وضروره خفض التوترات في فلسطين
والسودان من اجل ضمان وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه
نسعى لايجاد حل سياسي للوضع في سوريا يضمن
وحدتها وسيادتها ويلبي طموحات شعبها
بالتوافق مع القانون الدولي ويمتثل
لقرارات مجلس الامن نحن ايضا ملتزمون بخفض
التوترات بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
وابقاء افق الامل والعمل على حل الدولتين
وفي السودان واستجابه للازمه الاخيره نحن
نعمل بشكل مستمر على اسكات فوهات البنادق
والضغط لفتح ممرات المساعدات الانسانيه من
اجل مساعده الشعب السوداني على تحقيق
اماله والنقطه التي نركز عليها هي ان
انخراطنا معكم انتم شركائنا في الخليج
[موسيقى]
اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع في السودان قوات
الجيش بقصف سوق الموالح بام درمان جوا مما
ادى الى مقتل واصابه عشرات المدنيين ونشرت
الدعم السريع مقاطع لما تقول انه قصف
طيران الجيش لسوق الموالح بين ما لم يصدر
الجيش السوداني اي بيان حول تفاصيل الحادث
اما الخارجيه السودانيه فاعلنت ان قوات
الدعم الساريه اقتحمت سفارات الصين
وفلسطين ومنزل السفير العماني وتمت
الوزارات الدعم السريع بسرقه سيارات
دبلوماسيه من السفاره الصينيه والعبث
بمستنداتها وتعذيب عدد من عمال السفاره
الفلسطينيه
هذا وتشتد المعارك في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم منذ عده ساعات بين الجيش وقوه
الدعم السريع وشهدت عده احياء في العاصمه
الخرطوم وام درمان تصاعد اعمده الدخان
وسماعه ذوي انفجارات وافادت مصادر للعربيه
ان الجيش هجوما لقوات الدعم السريع جنوب
الخرطوم فيما نفذت قوات الدعم السريع هجوم
من اربعه محاور في مدينه الجنينه اسفره عن
مقتل وسقوط عده اشخاص وقالت قوات الدعم
السريع في بيان لها ان الجيش استهدف منطقه
مستودعات تحتوي على مواد قابله للاشتعال
ما تسبب في اضرار كبيره بمبان وحاويه
للوقود
[موسيقى]
وبخ وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي الى كوهين
نائبه الرئيس الامريكي كما لحارس بسبب
الانتقادات التي وجهتها لخطط التعديلات
القضائيه في اسرائيل
وراها نقاهن خلال مقابله اذاعيه على انه
اذا سال هاريس عما يزعجها في هذه
التعديلات القضائيه فانها لن تستطيع الرد
لكن ما الذي قالته نائب الرئيس الامريكي
تحديدا خلال حفل في سفاره اسرائيل لدى
واشنطن هارس قالت ان ديمقراطيه اسرائيل
تتطلب وجود قضاء مستقل مؤكده ان بلادها
ستواصل الدفاع عن القيام التي تشكل حجر
الاساس في العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
وانها ستتمسك بدعم الديمقراطيه في البلدين
التي تستند الى مؤسسات قويه وضوابط
وتوازنات وايضا قضاء مستقل
ومن الناصره ينضم الينا المحلل السياسي
نظير مجلي اهلا بك معنا الليله سيد نظير
يعني هذا التناس الذي حصل بين كمال كميلا
هاريس وايضا اليكوهن هل يعزز النظريه التي
تقول بانه هناك فجوه حقيقيه بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل ولن تحل او
تردم بوجود هكذا حكومه
مساء الخير لك المشاهدين المشاهدات اجل
هذا هو اتجاه هنالك مشكله جديه لكن ليس مع
الولايات المتحده بل مع الاداره الامريكيه
وحكومه اسرائيل يعني على صعيد العسكري
والاستراتيجي هنالك علاقات ممتازه نتنياهو
يحاول ان يستبعد الحوار المباشر مع
الاداره الامريكيه ولكن يترك الحبل على
غاربه
لمساعده لرفاقه في الحكومه ان ينفردوا على
الولايات المتحده هنالك غضب في الاداره هي
الحكومه الاسرائيليه من الاداره الامريكيه
يشعرون بان الحكومه الامريكيه لها دور في
الهبه الاحتجاز التي
تتجه للمساس بحكومه اسرائيل وربما اسقاطها
وهذا الامر يعبر عنه رفاق نتنياهو بكلماته
او اخرى وطبعا خصوصا وان هذا الاجتماع
الذي جرى في السفاره الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه في واشنطن كان لدعم اسرائيل
وكان الحضور فيه من غالبيه اليهود
الامريكان الذين صفقوا لهريس عمليا هم
ايضا شركاء في الانتقاد للحكومه
الاسرائيليه ولكن كيف لحكومه اسرائيليه ان
تستمر بلا رضا
الحكومه او الاداره الامريكيه التي تقول
بانه المشكله معها وليست مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
سيدنا مثل هذه الفتره في فتره اداره
الرئيس اوباماء عندما كان نتنياه ايضا
رئيسا للحكومه
وحاول نتنياهو بايدن من جهتهما في خلال
الاشهر الماضيه ان لا
يعودوا الى تلك الايام ولكن هذه الحكومه
فيها
جناح يميني متطرف ياخذها الى اتجاهات
صداميه في الشارع الفلسطيني في المنطقه
يهدد باشعال المنطقه بالتوتر ويدخل في
صدام مباشر مع الاداره الامريكيه وسياستها
لدرجه ان مثل هذا الصدام يعني يسعق الكثير
من المسؤولين الاسرائيليين الجنرال على
سبيل المثال الذي كان رئيسا للدائره
الامنيه السياسيه في وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه يقول انا اضرب على راسي عندما
اسمع وزراء في اسرائيل يتحدثون هكذا عن
امريكا فاذا كنا فعلا نريد ان نخوض معارك
لمصلحه اسرائيل واستراتيجيات الامنيه ضد
ايران مثلا لم نستطيع ذلك من دون الولايات
المتحده فاي جنون هذا يقوم به الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تجاه الامريكان في مثل هذه
الظروف فهذا الامر يقلق ويزعج الكثير من
الاسرائيليين ايضا وليس فقط الامريكيه سيد
نظير يعني ما المتوقع منا تنياهو للخروج
من هذه الازمه مع الاداره الامريكيه هل
سيعمد الى افتعال ازمه اخرى او فتح ملف
اخر
كما يتهمه منتقدوه بان هذه هي سياسته
افتعال ازمات لتشتيت الانتباه عن الازمه
الحقيقيه
نعم هذا اسلوب ولكنه في الواقع هو غاضب
جدا وغاضب بشكل حقيقي من السياسه
الامريكيه اولا عدم دعوته الى الولايات
المتحده رمى مرور خمسه شهور على تسلمه
الحكم مع انه عاده اعتاد الامريكيون ان
يدعو رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بعد شهرين
على الاكثر لكي يزوروا الولايات المتحده
ويلتقون مع ويلتقوا مع الرئيس
لا يوجه هذه الدعوه لانه يشعر بالفعل في
ان اسرائيل اتخذت خطه
تلحق ضررا بالمصالح المشتركه للولايات
المتحده واسرائيل فهذه ليست خطه اصلاح
قضائي هذه خطه انقلاب على انظمه الحكم في
اسرائيل وهدفها سياسي يعني جاءت لكي تضمن
ان لا يكون هناك حل القضيه الفلسطينيه
جاءت لكي تقود ايضا المصالح الخاصه بالحزب
الديمقراطي الامريكي جاءت لارضاء جناح
اليمين المتطرف في الحزب الجمهوري
الامريكي ففي الولايات المتحده يدركون هذا
الدور الاسرائيلي وفي اسرائيل يدركون هذا
الدور الامريكي ولذلك هم على طريق صدام
تشاوه
ونتنياهو يحاول ان يسير بين النقاط في
الوقت الحاضر كي لا يكون هذا
الصدام مباشر
ومثير اكثر للعلاقات بين البلدين ولكن هو
بحاجه ايضا اليه لكي يخرج من الازمه
الشخصيه التي يدخل فيها في هذه في الحكم
في اسرائيل شكرا ج من الناصره المحلل
السياسي نظير مجله
[موسيقى]
شدد دبلوماسي اوروبي في تصريحات للعربيه
على انه لم يعد ممكنا العوده الى الاتفاق
النووي بشكل الحالي الذي كان على الطاوله
في اغسطس الماضي وقال ان اي اتفاق نووي مع
ايران يجب ان يتم التفاوض عليه منذ
البدايه واضاف الدبلوماسي الاوروبي انه لا
يمكن اغلاق تحقيق المواقع السريه من دون
اجابات مقبوله من قبل ايران من جهتها
ابلغت السفيره الامريكيه لورا هولغايت
مجلس المحافظين بوكاله الطاقه ان اجوبه
ايران لم تكن مصحوبه بادله وان المجلس يجب
ان يكون مستعدا لمحاسبتها واضافت ان وصول
ايران ليورانيوم مخصب بنسبه 83% لا يجب ان
يتكرر ابدا
البعض يفكر في الاستسلام الدراسي بعد
الرسوب مره لكن في الصين مره سبا 26 مره
ولم يستسلم تابعونا بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قدم نائب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق مايك بانس اوراقه رسميا
للانضمام الى قائمه مرشحي الحزب الجمهوري
للرئاسه لعام 2020 من المقرر ان يطلق فانز
حملته رسميا في ولايه ايوا وهي الولايه
الاولى التي ستدلي باصواتها في ترشيح
الحزب الجمهوريه
[موسيقى]
يطرح نفسه كزعيم لمدرسه رونالد ريجن
التقليديه مسلحا بمبادئ الحزب المحافظه
استراتيجيته تعتمد على مهاجمه الرئيس
بايدن لكن نائب الرئيس السابق مايك بينس
لا يذكر اسم الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في اعلانه الترشح لانتخابات الرئاسه ويطلق
حملته الانتخابيه من ولايه ايوا التي
تعتبر نقطه الانطلاق نحو البيت الابيض
هي المكان الذي شكلنا فيه قيادتنا
المحافظه ايا وهي الولايه التي تحدد معالم
مرشح الانتخابات ويجب ان اخبركم انه خلال
العامين الماضيين امضينا انا وكارينا
الكثير من الوقت في التفكير والصلاه بشان
كل ما يواجه بلدنا وما يمكننا فعله للخدمه
نائب الرئيس السابق ينضم رسميا الى عدد من
مرشحين الجمهوريين الذين يتحدون رئيسهم
السابق مثل نيكي هيلي حاكمه ولايه السابقه
والسنتر تمسكوت الجمهوريه الوحيد الذي
ينحدر من اصول افريقيه لكن التحدي الحقيقي
للرئيس ترامب ياتي من حاكم فلوريدا
انا متاكد من ان ترامب يفكر كالتالي انا
من صنع مايك بينس فقد كان حاكم ولايتي
للمره الثانيه ولم يسمع به احد من قبل لكن
اي شكر حصلت عليه منه لم يقبل بانس بتجاوز
دستور الولايات المتحده في السادس من
يناير والان هذا الرجل يترشح للانتخابات
ضدي
جميع المرشحين يجربون حدودهم ويعرضون
اجدتهم المحافظه اجتماعيا وماليا ويهاجمون
الرئيس بايدن ويعتبرونه فاشلا في انقاذ
الاقتصاد وترد القيم الاجتماعيه
لكن البعض يرى ان العدد المتزايد للمرشحين
سيعطي افضليه للرئيس ترامب حيث ستتوزع
الاصوات بينهم ويصبح هو الفائز والبعض
الاخر يرى ان مشاكل ترم القانونيه قد
تمنعه من الترشح في النهايه
حتى الان
حاكم ولايه نيوجيرسي السابق هو الوحيد بين
المرشحين الجمهوريين الذي بدا يهاجم
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بشكل جديد هذا
قد لا يؤثر في القاعده المخلصه الشعبيه
التي بقت وفيه للرئيس ترامب لكنه قد يؤثر
في النهايه في شريحه معينه من الحزب
الجمهوري التي لا تريد ان يكون ترامب هو
مرشح للحزب الجمهوري نادي البلبيسي
العربيه
[موسيقى]
تصريح اليوم اعيش حياه الراهب منذ شهور
استيقظ فجرا واغوص في الكتب 12 ساعه
التصريحان هو احد رموز الكفاح الصينيه هو
مليونير عصاميه في السادسه والخمسين يدخل
الامتحانات المؤهله للمرحله الجامعيه
للمره السابعه والعشرين في حياته تخيلوا
الشيء الذي سبقه نجله قبل 12 عاما الى
الجامعه يقول انه لن يستسلم وانه سيظل
يطارد الشهاده الجامعيه لانه امتلك المال
لكنه لا يريد ان يتخلى عن حلمه في ان يكون
مثقفا
اليوم من لندن لقطات معتاده لاطفال
يتعلمون السباحه للمره الاولى طبعا تحت
اشراف الاب والام لكن الجديد ان العائله
كلها من النمور
سرعه اليوم من نيويورك تايمز بتقرير سله
الضوء على اكتشاف فرعونيه مبهر رسم فني
يعود الاف السنين يكشف كيف برع الفراعنه
في رسم الطيور وتظهر الرسومات والالوان
كيف جسد الفراعنه الطيور المتوطنه وحتى
المهاجره ببراعه ودقه في الالوان وحتى
الوضع التشريحي للطيور كان له رمزيه معينه
تعكس طبيعه الطير وما اذا كان جارحا او
حتى اليفا تنقل نيويورك تايمز عن الخبراء
الذين حللوا هذه الصور ان الرسام الفرعوني
لم يكن له نظير في عصره بل وربما لو عاش
بيننا فلن يكون له نظير في هذا العصر ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لكم مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه
ننتقل الى زميل صهيب واخبار الساعه مساء
الخير صهيب مساء الخير يا راويه كالعاده
جوله سريعه شامله ومتنوعه لابرز اخبار
اليوم في اخبار الساعه في الصداره الوضع
في اوكرانيا الوضع في السودان وكذلك ازمه
جديده بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده تفضل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات